and now the results are bronze medal
winner is the film that you just saw
please welcome the bronze medal award
winning director of win or lose Daniel
Kolar wow it's such an incredible honor
to be up here um before I begin I just
want to thank the Academy for such a
fantastic week of events and and just
the opportunity to meet so many
fantastic people it's truly been an
honor to be here and I know all of us
filmmakers are appreciative of the
learning opportunities and the people
we've gotten a chance to meet and and
all those things that you set in motion
by inviting us here this week um I'd
like to start off by thanking the the
producer the film film live dubin Dorf
she did a fantastic job organizing
shoots wrestling down music lawyers and
just making sure everything ran smoothly
on said to live the film would not be
what it is without you so thank you um
also like to thank Neil Penninger the
the composer for the project for
agreeing to do another film with me as
well as my family especially my brothers
Mike and Josh who watched countless of
cuts and I know it's like that whole
thing don't show family cuts but I they
were really brutal trust me so I really
appreciate all their help um and of
course I also want to thank my mentors
to whom come from elon university where
i had a fantastic undergraduate
experience on it may sound cliche but I
don't think I would be a filmmaker let
alone be here at the Student Academy
Awards if it weren't for these people
Brooke Barnett my mentor who agreed to
mentor me since sophomore year when she
saw my first film Nicole Trish who
really championed this project win or
lose and sort of planted the idea in my
head that this film could actually be
good and most recently Marshall curry
who's really facilitated my transition
from school into the working world and
has been a tremendous encouragement so
thank you to the mall um last and not
least certainly not least i want to
thank curtis brown and the rest of the
vote against team for what they did and
for allowing us to follow them for six
months we've had someone here the
Academy following us around with a
camera every time the camera comes over
I'm like they're filming in miss filming
filming me now so I I finally know what
it's like Curtis south
you for being patient thank you for
being a for just being a great subject
at but more importantly thank you for
your project and for choosing to create
a portrait of North Carolina unity and
for allowing living me to take that
portrait beyond state borders to as you
say change hearts and inspire minds in
the struggle for marriage equality thank
you all